[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre ici au Parlement
européen de Bruxelles attaché vos
ceintures direction la lune à les
Américains viennent de lancer avec
succès la fusée Artémis qui marque le
début du programme américain de retour
sur la lune prélude au un futur voyage
vers Mars d'ailleurs ils sont suivis de
très près par des chinois qui
investissent massivement dans la course
aux étoiles à la fin de l'année Pékin
orage fait avec succès sa station
spatiale Tian donc qui veut dire le
palais céleste l'Europe est-elle à la
traîne l'autonomie d'accès des Européens
à l'espace est actuellement fragilisé
par le retard de trois ans de la fusée
Ariane qui finalement ne sera mise en
service que fin 2026 et alors pour
tenter de rester dans la course aux
étoiles l'Agence spatiale européenne les
a voit son budget augmenter de 17% soit
17 milliards d'euros entre 2023 et 2025
mais lors des choix a sonné les amis
moins sur les vols habités qui font
révéler foule pour se sur les
constellations de satellites un enjeu
stratégique sur le plan militaire des
communications et dans la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique sommes-nous
à l'aube d'une nouvelle conquêtes
spatiales et bien pour en débattre nous
recevons exceptionnellement 3 invités
Daniel Freud écologiste allemand bonjour
bienvenue à vous vous votre pays
l'Allemagne qui est le premier
contributeur de les à l'Agence spatiale
européenne et puis avec nous aussi 2
euros députés du groupe centriste
réunion avec des rapports plus ou moins
distendus à l'espace la République
tchèque finalement a l'agence européenne
véritablement de la Commission sur son
sol et elle est un membre bien sûr plus
récent de les actes les la France par
exemple Christophe rugler second
contributeur avec quelques ratés on a
envie de dire au décollage moins
d'investissement lisait que nos rivaux
américains et chinois et ce qu'on est en
train de manquer le train de l'espace
non je pense qu'il faut relativiser un
petit peu tout ça quand vous parlez
d'Artémis c'est de la fusée qui va sur
la lune c'est pas un problème américain
ça prend international avec
participation européenne puisque les
européens font notamment le module qui
permet à la capsule Orion d'aller faire
les navettes sur la lune donc c'est un
enjeu pour l'Europe de rester dans ce
partenariat avec la NASA dans l'espace
comme dans toute science la coopération
internationale est majeure pour les
Européens donc on est présent par ce
biais là on a également des outils de
précision qui sont les meilleurs au
monde que les Américains ou que d'autres
étapes prennent parce que parce qu'on
est les meilleurs simplement je pense
qu'il faut pas développer la culture du
complexe faut qu'on soit au contraire
fier de nous on investit quand même
chaque année pratiquement 10 milliards
d'euros au sein de l'Europe donc une
partie 2,5 pour le pour l'Union
européenne en tant que telle mais 10
milliards en comptant tous les tous les
États membres donc on a une vraie
volonté quand même de d'avoir cet accès
autonome à l'espace qui assure notre
indépendance quelque part et le fait
qu'on ait notre avenir en main quelle
est la priorité pour les trois ans à
venir pour les êtres et clairement la
priorité européenne c'est réussir la
constellation de satellites européens
Iris qui est une grande constellation de
télécommunications qui va quelque part
concurrencer la constellation privée de
Monsieur musk qui en fonction de ses
humeurs sur l'Ukraine ou autre fait un
peu ce qu'il veut il y a un engin de
souveraineté pour l'Union européenne
avec je suis très content en tant que
rapporteur pour le Parlement d'avoir
réussi l'accord politique au sein même
du Parlement entre tous les groupes et
également en négociation avec le
conseiller la commission donc maintenant
on a un projet qui fait l'unanimité qui
va nous permettre peut-être demain
d'aider l'Ukraine avec la
télécommunication avec de l'accès
Internet partout en Europe
elle est pas assez complète nous on a un
système bien plus complexe mais moins
cher où on va mettre en relation des
satellites de base sur beat avec des
satellites géostationnaires de très
grande orbites pour avoir moins besoin
de lancer une satellite on va peut-être
avoir besoin de 200 satellites là où
Monsieur mask il en veut 20 000
mettre dans la coopération parce que il
y a tellement peu d'acteurs dans le
spatial si les États qui investissent
dans le spatial veulent tous faire la
même chose si il y a une compétition en
interne au lieu d'être dans la
compétition mondiale on va faire des
erreurs clairement on a un lanceur lourd
qui s'appelle Ariane 6 qui va être lancé
en 2023 il faut que ce soit un succès il
y a pas le choix après on peut regarder
s'il y a d'autres types de lanceurs qui
peut être développé avec qui mais il
faut pas qu'on va y faire tous
la position de l'Allemagne moi je pense
que sur le marché des micro lanceurs ou
aujourd'hui il y a pas encore de
business case ça coûte assez cher mais
pourquoi pas partager avec peut-être des
Allemands les Italiens une réflexion sur
ces lanceurs de demain priorité au
lanceur européen c'est ce qu'on a déjà
écrit dans notre texte sur la
constellation priorité au lanceur
donc en fait c'est voilà c'est notamment
Ariane mais peut-être que demain il part
d'autres acteurs Vegas donc c'est les
Italiens donc voilà donc mais ça marche
enfin Ariane 6 sur une technologie assez
nouvelle qui va permettre de lancer 10
fois moins cher 5 kg dans l'espace donc
c'est un véritable progrès mais alors je
compte sur notre amialement pour
convaincre son gouvernement de lancer
par exemple les satellites militaires
allemands de pas lui lancer par Space X
mais de choisir aussi de lancer européen
parce que c'est là aussi on peut être
solidaire et s'entraider mais je peux
pas laisser dire que SpaceX c'est moins
cher pas vrai SpaceX c'est gavé dessus
par derrière par le gouvernement
américain pour faire du dumping sur le
marché commercial là où les Européens
étaient leaders parce que notre notre
industrie spatiale et c'est développé
sur le commerce privé des satellites
géostationnels il y a quelques années
aujourd'hui oui alors il y a un
rééquilibrage c'est-à-dire que nous en
Europe on n'a pas mis beaucoup d'argent
public en disant les vols commerciaux
suffisent à financer l'espace sauf que
les satellites géostationnaires
descendent de plus en plus au profit de
satellites en bas sur moins lourd
et sur lesquels maintenant il y a plus
de marché donc il y a plus besoin de
subventions afin de financement public
on va dire pour pour notre industrie
spatiale alors qu'aux États-Unis c'est
le contraire ils doivent essayer de
récupérer des parts de marché commercial
donc il y a des subventions par derrière
tour de table vous avez derrière vous
les visages souriants les anciens envoi
Thomas Pesquet les nouveaux la nouvelle
promotion d'astronautes de Lisa avec
notamment la française Sophie Adnot il y
a aussi un Allemand et un check mais qui
sont malheureusement parmi les
réservistes est-ce que vous les enviez
est-ce que vous autres rêves c'est
d'aller dans l'espace monsieur creux de
l'air un très grand souvenir pour moi
c'est d'avoir été à la veille du
lancement de Thomas Pesquet avec lui à
Cap Canaveral la veille de son lancement
et c'est vrai que quand on voit les
étoiles qu'ils ont dans les yeux ça fait
vraiment rêver et je suis très heureux
pour la française parce que l'originaire
de ma région la Bourgogne Franche-Comté
donc c'est une grande joie